savez vous que c'est la troisième
édition du mois de l'architecturé
contemporaine
dit comme ça et ce n'est pas forcément
un très sexy mais vous allez voir
comment elle peut s'inspirer des
bâtiments qui existe déjà on en parle
tout de suite avec d'arrière ankara le
mois de l'architecturé contemporaine art
sa mère est inaccessible dit comme ça
mais l'objectif c'est bien de donner des
clés de compréhension au public les
phares te fais tout à fait
de quelle manière c'est un effet à un
moment privilégié pour sensibiliser et
diffuser la culture de la chine
contemporaine bourgogne auprès du grand
public parce qu'un effet la même s'il on
vit tout le temps dans notre cadre bâti
entre les des architectures on connaît
pas forcément bien et ont cédé comme non
plus mis en valeur la larve de cette
architecture et pour cela en fait la
maison de l'architecturé de bourgogne
avec le soutien d'un réseau de
partenaires parce que c'est très
important leur présence c'est à
organiser en fait la troisième édition
parce que ses sharks 2 ans pour en fait
diffuser sur les amis du raid à moi
cette année serment et demi avec une
série d événements des conférences des
visites sur le dos des différentes en
fait architecture contemporaine qui
existe les différentes oeuvres 15x en
bourgogne
donc c'est organisé sur les quatre
départements avec les quelques
événements aussi en franche-comté 31
décembre j'avais d'autres questions à
vous poser mais monde et le plateau pour
poursuivre avec cette visite guidée
proposée à l'envi je vous en parle il ya
un moment de la visite guidée dans un
gymnase
je vous propose de regarder sujet puis
en continuant par ailleurs après sa
forme sombre a surgi dans le paysage en
début d'année dans ce quartier
résidentiel de longvic le gymnase
véronique pecqueux-rolland attire les
regards
tout en longueur et en transparence
de voir un matériel de construction et
il ya finalement seulement la partie qui
est sous sol et quelques brûlures sont
enfuis emportant ce lundi les
architectes patrick très muller et
isabel sénéchal chevallier font visiter
le bâtiment
l'occasion pour le grand public de
découvrir leur travail des façades
chacune différente des matériaux
innovants comme le béton étanche et
intérêts ont intérêt à 3 mètres 50
la conception est née simplement la
question qu'est ce que c'est m gymnase
alors ça c'est quand même un lieu de
rencontre pour les cours des gens qui
font le sport mais aussi pour les
visiteurs et c'est pour ça c'était très
important pour nous d'avoir une
construction qui est ouvert alors on
voit depuis l'extérieur pour regarder
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
mais la même chose dans l'autre sens
alors si vous êtes assis sur les rangées
voyez qu'est ce qui se passe dehors
ces visites sont organisées avec le sait
a eu le conseil d'architecturé
d'urbanisme et de l'environnement de
côte-d'or dix fois par an des
architectes font découvrir des bâtiments
singulier une porte ouverte sur l'
architecture contemporaine qui réjouit
les visiteurs il ya la promenade dans le
site en petit chai est effectivement
aller dans des angles
normalement quand enquête
visiteurs c'est au niveau du résultat et
des explications qu'on essaye de
comprendre
j'ai bien essayé parce que tout ça c'est
dans la tête de l'architecte c'est lui
qui a quitté crise du sens fort c'est la
saison idéale pour découvrir des lieux
atypiques le mois de l'architecturé a
commencé vendredi
oui donc il a commencé mi-septembre mais
se passer jusqu'à la fin du mois donc on
parle d'architecturé contemporaine on
parle de quelle époque finalement on
parle de surtout de notre présent de
l'architecturé contemporaine de nos
derniers quinze et dix ans et son
architecture en tout cas qui est
vraiment lié à un seul étage du bâtiment
en fait de notre région et il dira qu'il
s'inspire déjà de ce qui existe s'est
inspiré centre hélas et il poursuit en
fait là le témoignage est tout à fait
l'utilisation qu'on fait de 17 h lecture
donc ça veut dire des bâtiments à la
fois qui accueillent du public mais
aussi des bâtiments dans lesquels on
peut vivre bien sûr en fait on parle
qu'on parle d'attitude contemporaine on
part tout à fait de l'habitat individuel
de l'habitat collectif des équipements
donc des équipements scolaires sportifs
du tertiaire répond-t-il à des critères
particuliers je pensais la luminosité à
certains matériaux utilisés pour les
mettre en valeur
bah oui bien sûr la lumière c'est
toujours un point fondamental pour les
architectures mais au niveau de matériel
et concernant toujours là notre légion
surtout la construction en bois peut
être déjà eu vent un bon moyen
voilà pour la mettre en valeur parmi les
autres bien sûr donc si je vous
comprends bien ça veut dire que
l'architecturé contemporaine en
bourgogne ou en franche comté n'est pas
la même que celle d'alsace ou que celle
de bretagne
oui voilà tout à fait chaque les gens
pètent a développé avec cette addition
et avec aussi la présence et de des
écoles d'architecturé un certain
patrimoine le fait ici que nous
ghosn il n'existe pas en vraie école d
architecture n'a pas permis on va la
développer ce type d'architecturé c'est
pour celà fait que je te tue
contemporain et celle qui l'a les
architectes d'aujourd'hui aussi et c'est
de mettre en valeur ses l'achitecture
même mais parfois ce n'est pas évident
pour un architecte de pouvoir expliquer
la volonté qui la mettre dans un
bâtiment qu'il construit mais c'est pour
ça que c'est très important la le
rapport qui sont qui s'installe entre le
maître d'ouvragé est le maître d'oeuvre
est en fait c'est très intéressant
suivre et la toule lithaire le chemin
qui qui parle d'une idée et qui se
développe avec une conception et avec la
construction même
et oui ce n'est pas tout à fait mais
c'est important par contre ali le
résultat le connaître ses résultats
parce que c'est tout à fait les les
architectures ordinaire c'est le parc
sera ordinaire qu'on peut reconnaître
qu'ils font en fait qu'ici que notre
cadre bâti prend de la valeur
et c'est l'objectif de ce mode
architecture de pouvoir voir la valeur
que ces bâtiments
oui merci beaucoup d'être venu me
semblait donc de ce mois de l'
architecture contemporaine je vous
rappelle que c'est jusqu'au 30 octobre
et que vous pouvez bien sûr visiter
différents bâtiments pour se lève vers
le programme est détaillé sur notre site
internet merci à vous